THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. THE
FIRST BILL OF THE ORDER TODAY IS
SB 295 BOARD PILOT COMMISSIONERS,
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COMMITTEES
CURRENTLY MEETING. HOWEVER, IF
MEMBERS CAN TRY TO GET TO ROOM
1200 SO WE CAN DISPENSE WITH THE
BUSINESS IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE, THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED, WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 295 SB
EXCUSE ME, ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? GOOD MORNING. YOU GOT
TO GO FOR THAT PRESENTATION. I
MEAN, REALLY? YEAH I WAS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE OVER THE. I
WILL, I'LL DO THAT RIGHT NOW.
OKAY. DO WE HAVE AN AUTHOR FOR
ITEM NUMBER ONE? ANYBODY ANYBODY?
YEAH. I THOUGHT WE WERE REALLY
CRUISING TODAY. WE ARE CRUISING.
JUST DISPENSE FROM THE READING.
OH SENATOR DODD, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL? YES MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY, I'M
PRESENTING SB 295, WHICH IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE VOTE. THE BILL,
AS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY,
CREATES A NEEDED FLEXIBILITY IN
THE PILOT BOAT SURCHARGE ACCOUNT
BY AUTHORIZING THE BOARD OF
PILOT COMMISSIONERS TO COLLECT
BANK AND EXPEND FUNDS NECESSARY
TO REPLACE OR RE-ENGINEER PILOT
VESSELS WHILE SAVING ON
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST COSTS. THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
DID YOU BRING ANYBODY TO, I
MEAN, AN EXPERT WITNESS OR
ANYTHING TO INTERPRET THAT FOR
US? GO AHEAD SIR, I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF. THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR.
MATT ROBINSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION, BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
IN THE ROOM. I'LL GO AHEAD AND
MENTION OUR CO-SPONSORS, THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS AND CRUISE
LINES INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION,
ALL IN SUPPORT. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW US TO PAY OFF THOSE VESSEL
REPLACEMENTS SOONER WHILE SAVING
ABOUT $30 MILLION IN INTEREST.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT WHO'D LIKE TO COME UP
AND OFFER THEIR SUPPORT? YOU
WANT TO GO? GO AHEAD. IF NOT,
OH, IS SHE GOING TO RUN UP? YOU
GOT ME. OKAY. HE HAS. YOU ALL
RIGHT? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WANTS TO TESTIFY? NO.
OKAY, GOOD. IT COMES BACK TO THE
DÍAS. SENATOR BRADFORD, DID YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR SENATOR
DODD? NO. SO AND NEITHER DO I.
SO WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL
GET A VOTE ON THIS BILL. SO
IT'LL BE ON CALL OR NOT ON CALL.
IT'LL BE WAITING FOR YOU. VICE
CHAIR. SO DO WE HAVE WORD IN
RUBIO?
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, SB 536.
SENATOR RUBIO IS NOT IN THE
BUILDING, AND SENATOR SATO IS
GOING TO PRESENT THE BILL ON HER
BEHALF. ALL RIGHT. I'M ON HERE.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MISS
RUBIO. SO IT'S NOT FUNNY. IT IS
FUNNY. YOU JUST DON'T HAVE A
SENSE OF HUMOR THIS MORNING. NO,
I DON'T HAVE ONE AT ALL, SO FOR
TOO LONG, THE HERMAN J. G. STARK
YOUTH CORRECTIONAL FACILITY HAS
SAT CLOSED AND UNUSED IN THE
CITY OF CHINO. BASICALLY, WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS ENABLES THE
CITY OF CHINO TO PURCHASE THIS
LAND FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND THEY WILL MAKE
VARIOUS IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE VERY BENEFICIAL FOR
THE COMMUNITY OF CHINO. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME COMES AND I DON'T.
I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE AN EXPERT
WITNESS HERE WHO'S GOING TO
TESTIFY ON HOW MUCH HE LIKES THE
BILL. WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN, AND THANK YOU, SENATOR
SEYARTO, FOR PINCH HITTING JASON
GONSALVES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CHINO. THIS AS THE SENATOR
SAYS, ENABLES THE CITY TO BEGIN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH DGS. AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS. AND I GUESS IT'S YOUR
LAST CHAIRMANSHIP, SENATOR DODD.
SO THANK YOU FOR MAYBE YOU NEVER
KNOW. YOU NEVER KNOW HOW IT
ROLLS HERE. RIGHT. BUT IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. GONZALEZ.
APPRECIATE YOU. AND PLEASE LET
THE CITY OF CHINO KNOW THAT
SENATOR SATO DID THE HEAVY
LIFTING ON THIS ONE WITH
REINFORCEMENT. YOU NEVER KNOW.
YOU GOT IT. THANK HIS BROTHER,
SENATOR CIERTO ALSO WAS. NO, I'M
JUST KIDDING. OKAY, THAT WASN'T
FUNNY EITHER. IT WAS. YOU JUST
DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF HUMOR THIS
MORNING, OKAY? IS THERE ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION? THERE IS NONE.
WE'LL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. SENATOR WILK,
SHE ASKED ME SO YOU'RE GOING TO
ASK ME SOME HARD HITTING
QUESTIONS? I COULD DO IT BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE FUNNY, BUT OKAY, THE
MOTION IS WE DON'T NEED A MOTION
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM. SO WE ARE DONE
PRESENTING BILLS IN GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NEED TO COME DOWN AND VOTE. AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM. WE ARE
CLOSING THE ROLL. IT WILL. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO KEEP THE ROLL OPEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
STAFF MEMBER FROM LOS ANGELES
WHO CAME TO VISIT. HI ANTHONY.
EVERYONE WAVE TO ANTHONY. HE'S
RIGHT THERE. WAVE ANTHONY. LET
HIM KNOW THAT THAT IS HOW
SERIOUS YOU ARE ABOUT THE WORK.
THANK YOU FOR VISITING. YEAH,
EVERYONE WAVE. NO, I MEANT LIKE
THE WAVE.
ARE WE JUST OPENING THIS UP? THE
COMMITTEE WILL START IN 30S,
STARTING RIGHT NOW. BRADFORD, I
CAN BE OUT OF HERE IN 30S. I
HEARD THAT, YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
I CAN'T REMEMBER. ALL RIGHT, WE
ARE RECONVENING THE GEO
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT. IF WE
COULD CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. DODD WILK PRESENT.
WILK PRESENT. ARCHULETA. ASHBY
ASHBY. HERE. BRADFORD HERE.
BRADFORD. HERE. GLAZER. JONES
I'M HERE. JONES. HERE. NGUYEN.
HERE. NGUYEN. HERE OCHOA. B¢O.
PADILLA I PRESENT PADILLA
PRESENT. PORTANTINO ROTH. ROTH.
HERE. RUBIO. PRESENT RUBIO.
PRESENT. CELADO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. HERE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
HERE. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE'VE ALREADY HAD BILL
PRESENTATIONS. SO I'M JUST GOING
TO RECAP AND THEN WE'LL PUT IT
TO A VOTE. ITEM NUMBER ONE WAS
FROM THE CHAIR SB 295. THE
MOTION WAS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN, JUST
TO RECAP, THE BILL REMOVES CAPS
ON ANNUAL SPENDING FROM THE
PILOT BOAT SURCHARGE ACCOUNT IN
THE BOARD OF PILOTS.
COMMISSIONER SPECIAL FUND, WHICH
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS TO COVER
COSTS OF OBTAINING NEW BOATS AND
FUNDING DESIGN AND ENGINEERING
MODIFICATIONS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
EXTENDING THE SERVICE LIFE OF
EXISTING BOATS, EXCLUDING COSTS
FOR REPAIR AND MAINTENANCE.
CLEARLY THE FIRST TIME WITH
THAT, LET'S CALL THE VOTE DODD
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. GLASER. JONES
AYE. JONES. AYE. NGUYEN OCHOA.
BOAT OKUBO. AYE PADILLA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
ROTH PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO CIERTO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD.
AYE. DODD. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. GLASER YES.
NGUYEN YEAH. WE HAD ONE THREE
3413. WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
MOMENTARILY. EVERYBODY KNOW
EVERYBODY'S EVERYBODY'S HERE.
WHAT ABOUT GLASER OF COURSE.
OKAY, SO THAT'S, BILL IS OUT 13
ZERO. WE CANNOT SHOW UP. I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT. YEAH, I KNOW
I'M OUT OF HERE. LET'S GO TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON, SB 536. I'M A NO ON
THIS. DO YOU HAVE A MOTION? NO,
I'LL MAKE A MOTION BECAUSE
SENATOR CIERTO DID A GREAT JOB
PRESENTING, SENATOR RUBIO'S BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK MOTION.
SENATOR WILK, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DODD. AYE DODD AYE. WILK
AYE. WILK AYE. ARCHULETA. Ã
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
AYE. GLASER. JONES A. JONES AYE.
NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE. OCHOA B¢O.
AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE CIERTO. CIERTO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
PORTANTINO 1414. BILL IS OUT 14
ZERO. THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE GEO
COMMITTEE. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.